9くっや集めるぜうまぁ今でも風邪にはよくユーエスタック
ドーン肇社長ですペグズー
というわけで今日は何ですけどもあの骨が dj ブースクラブ初めからを止めさせ
手続の pa
[音楽]
ブービーみたいなぬーんぬーくださっフロアを明かすわぁフロア
ます風呂を沸かすこれを沸かすそれを沸かすするを沸かす風呂を沸かすそ
お風呂を沸かすんです今の原理かというともうお風呂を沸かすのとフロアを沸かせ乗っ
てほぼ一緒な意味なのできょるのがですね今からお風呂を使う査定しますって嘘ついて
みんなお風呂を使う動画を取ると思ってるんですけどもみんなと言って僕がちょっと
風呂を渡してくれはって言ったら
ロア沸かせるドッキリやっていきたいとおもいます
何かそれをですね dj ブースみたいな還元してもらっておりますからもう完全に
フロアですね僕はターゲット人たちにフローを明かしてくるねーって言って風呂に行か
ずにフロアに入って風呂を渡してくると言うとかになっております果たしてウィンナー
はプロじゃなくて苦労は沸かせたらどういう反応するのかアーンスト分厚いコート本名
プレス4
ここが今日のスクバでへ
みんなのせるかぁあああああ
というわけでいいますけど私てくるはスーツて結果不和を合わせているということで
みんなところに行ってきたいと思います皆待っててくれよ
ん
お待たせしましたために一人ずついるんだよねー
誰かれてます
どっ速かななんかお風呂っ関連のフロー図ん
トレッタナッツくるか打つと区
風呂沸かしてくるから3分ぐらいの2階の部屋に来てください
follow 私いきます
[音楽]
me to war
アクセをます
ん
[音楽]
ビルガー
[拍手]
re
[音楽]
[拍手]
up いやーこれはいいいっ
ame
[拍手]
male
me
car
[音楽]
me
tee
amane
ウールわけで色を渡して決まっていったようない
黒じゃなくてフロアブラシてきましたーー
[拍手]
me
んあーショット俺の dje スキルが足んなかったけど次阿蘇は言わせねぇ
任せるぜフードはそして吹かせる全部ロワーを得てああ
ってるぞこれぞ
もう苦労空いてるから
[音楽]
ん
潤あああああ
me
san
car
[拍手]
ana
rar
あああああええええ
ana
へいへい
me
nan
ええええええ
re
強くまあまあ枚板ってどこかな
すっ
遠田町規定これは長谷とるからなあ
th
[音楽]
ええええええ
dj
ううっうぅううああああっ
jalan ampang
[拍手]
[音楽]
ん
ずれこのたか俺苦労を開いてるって言ったよな
加えているのは黒じゃなくてグーンうわあ
[拍手]
それが予約できこれませんか
あの2回の乳業するやで
動いてるねー
[音楽]
話すずらすだ薄みんなこれが最後のトラックらー
ふーん
あああああ2
none
[音楽]
jr
わー2
me
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
持っていた
ano onna 位
ana
me
yeah
teal
me
ana あああっ